ciao a tutti tutto il cibo che mangiamo
farla franca gita avete visto allora
come si può capire soprattutto del
tifoso e nutella oggi andremo a testare
dei trucchetti di five minutes kraft che
in italiano ai 5 minuti creativi andiamo
a testare a un'élite max trucchetti
ovest a fatica i tantissimi di fare
questo video mi ha fatto alcuni anni fa
con rimettere i link magari alla fine di
questo video che cosa si andare a vedere
i miei comando lasciato un bel live
se volete vedere altri trucchetti se
un'organizzazione o altre semplici pure
nei commenti fuori volete che testiamo
noi abbiamo scelto alcuni invader alla
semplicità perché sono facilissimi da
fare e soprattutto quelle che si possono
mangiare non solo speriamo che si è
strano che faremo vedere il trucchetto
originale così potrete comparare
l'originale con quello che è riuscito a
noi siete bravi prendete negativi un po
corrente calda o bella azione di casa
vedere i video tutto schermo e iniziamo
subito per il primo trucchetto
[Musica]
e profumo allora propone questo
trucchetto vitale ammessi micron della
nutella per quanto tempo trenta secondi
però non troppo potente il microonde
azionato a 705 650 watt
ok e poi button tutta tutta la carta
argentata se non pericolosi stima si
rompe il fronte pure voi oppure la
potete mettere in un contenitore
comunque che i profughi
poi dobbiamo quindi per una parata
gliela fece allora quindi per riprodurre
questo trucchetto
prendiamo una lampadina quel rumore era
la stella lebron e vernici di strano ma
questo tagliamo la banana
vi facciamo delle fette sì questo filo
un brutto questo nome giuseppe
abbastanza spessa che poi dobbiamo
mettere il bastoncino potete usare
magari dell'oste scadenti iniziare a
mangiare tutto e poi fa allora poi parla
come avete potuto vedere
bisogna farsi aiutare da un adulto per
tagliare la banana in questo caso io ho
preso la banana e la stoppa uragani
allora nessuno sito tantissimo devo dire
vabbè comunque abbiamo noi da questi
bastoncini che avevamo da un sacco di
tempo
però potete usare degli stuzzicadenti in
amoretto pensi ma ha pure degli spiedini
ma come vediamo un po se l'è di legno
tipo che stuzzica del tonio nord
infischia
il primo è carina ovviamente stiamo
fissando tutti questi effetti di banana
con questi con questi bastoncini
stecchini che sono questi sistemi di
legno qualche stecchini per fare il
super positivo sono per il cake box di
fake cops che prima o poi lo faremo
perché buoni è capire come peso in più
la nutella
[Musica]
allora proviamo con il primo sperando
che la bat
vabbè che come la maggiore comunque
allora selvaggio si vada colpo carriera
immergiamo la nutella e adesso rimandate
[Musica]
si è indurita ok dai baci volata questi
myfax sono spettacolari e adesso potete
mandarla e poi mettiamo le nostre
decorazioni va beh procediamo prima con
l'altra la modella proprio pratica per
fare queste cose qui a lato la bella e
difficile ricoprirlo cosa stai facendo
tu ti stai mangiando tutta la modella e
io qui al voto con la camera in mano no
no devo fare io però non sono letti
coperto
il pezzo di banana k diciamo che questi
live fax sono un po particolari da apple
non mangiare tutto no appiccicoso e
quindi si stacca facilmente poi dallo di
una banana staccato al bastoncino dove
questi sono sei mesi
due mesi fa lo zio detenuti allora ora
mettiamo delle decorazioni o queste per
torta lei allora vediamo questo schifo
io sarah kang e decorazioni riparazioni
sono molto più carini si aiuta tanto per
ma fermo devo finire
non ci posso credere guarda che ti
aspetta almeno quelli finiamo stato io
mamma mia
erano completi diciamo che sono diversi
da quelli del del trucchetto
era meno semplice di quanto sembrasse
però ora andiamo a festeggiare allora
date di questo risultato del primo
trucchetto non sono uguali ma penso che
non abbia notato un altra cioccolato
cioccolato scelta aiuto dai quello
possiamo assaggiare sbagliarla
becker taccola alta con l'altra sa già
come leone no no va bene sentito bene ve
lo posso dare a classico federa
[Musica]
preparatevi perché l'italia viterale
impazzire una fiammata di zucchero
quindi di vecchi che voto date a questo
trucchetto da 1 a 10 venendo il nostro
risultato
voto 10 allora trucchetto e numero due
[Musica]
in tutto il corpo
andiamo vediamo un po sono davvero
dispiaciuto la banana mamma guarda lo
sapevo ma web ma che ora la
riempiamo di nutella
prendiamo la nostra siringa per dolci o
salati la cucina vediamo eccoli la
nutella
hai mai stato troppo curioso vediamo to
scoraggiato la banana
mi sembra che sta cambiando colore la
busana e 3 pronome si sarebbe chiuso
notiamo mettiamone ancora un po
fitto la banana di nutella
finito questo è stato molto più semplice
invece ora possiamo tagliarlo a fette
vai o e bellissima tenuto bene ma potevi
aspettare momento gioco anch'io
questo è per me va bene togliamo ancora
un altro pezzo di m 2 stortoni andora
quasi un po ro ma non è proprio diritto
come la denuncia quindi però comunque è
riuscito ora assaggiamo anche se tu hai
già mangiata io e vediamo ancora ma che
finalmente posso assaggiarla come l idea
magari si può così bastano il mondo
troppa ok entrati in questo trucchetto
come fanno vedere anche nelle copertine
dei loro video se lo schermo graffiato
del telefono con del dentifricio dovrete
o riparazione non vedersi noi abbiamo
qua il telefono e stupidità tale rock e
graffiato lo facciamo l'inquadratura da
vicino proviamo anche noi
l'ufficio vediamo se cambia qualcosa
allora vedete qua con schermino è rotto
eccoli qui possiamo appunto vedere se
andrà via
magicamente con il dentifricio
magicamente e adesso si ritrova scende
dello schermo vediamo se c'è ancora
sì così si vede di più vero che lo
schermo acceso
[Musica]
mi raccomando eh non mi rovinate il
telefono
prendo un pochettino metto al centro
dovete stare attenti a non metterlo
fuori qua dove c'è la camera duramente
[Musica]
spagnolo e speriamo che non rovineremo
per sempre il telefono chiaro allora
soprattutto qua nella crepa
poi è anche sporco il telefono quindi
magari lo pulisce perbene profumerà
finalmente
guardate possono disegnare le rotte
ok non so per quanto tempo dopo
spalmarlo su uno basta allora io lo
credo
però forse adesso che lo togliamo
magicamente sparirà
[Musica]
non era forse sparita davvero il mio
telefono poi ritorna bello nuovo
profumato potrebbe però far sì che
[Musica]
proviamo a tirare via un po di
dentifricio ma tu la vedi la crepa no
aspetta giochiamo bene e poi lo
analizziamo meglio tra l'altro quasi
telefono non è neanche waterproof cioè
non è resistente all'acqua
ma duke è brutto tutto appiccicoso
insomma il peggio di prima volta o quasi
quasi neanche si vede
[Musica]
vediamo come sembra si è vero sembra
avuto che sporco di prima un gran porco
poi il taglio c'è la spaccatura tipo
effettivamente non sembra cioè non
l'avete poi pro proprio bene sembra
quasi chiusa ma forse si è chiusa perché
c'è il dentifricio ten troviamo che ha
detto modificata a togliere togliere
tutto il dentifricio
ok era molto bella molto più pulita
aperta per si vede anche alla spaccatura
vediamo questa terra bene qua e qui
forse un pochino di meno verosimile
proviamo ad asciugarlo ora dopo questa
sessione di polizia buffon
anzi di lavatura di denti profonda
scrivete di meno però dobbiamo vederlo
da un'altra angolazione
secondo me non ha funzionato
però questa si nota un po di meno o
forse solo poche perché è pulito no ok
ho guardato adesso si vede ancora
accadeva nulla
questa cosa del dentifricio la bufala
guarda come si vede ricevo da tra questi
ci dispiace veramente un po più pulito
lo schermo almeno lo scandaloso e
proprio pulito ma magari è stata la star
di età fanno bene quindi questa storia
del dentifricio degli schermo funziona
allora federer in tour i trucchetti che
abbiamo testato da five minutes scrubs
cosa ne pensi allora quello modella
delle banane validi tutti giù a kakà il
primo di più vero forse era più pratico
pure secondo
poi uscito un po brutto però è
importante mangiare a che fare con lo
stesso invece non hanno funzionato
proprio non non è un buon un buon
trucchetto di o forse non ti piace come
truccatori non è potuto mancare niente
fateci sapere col quale mi è piaciuto il
mio dei tre trucchetti a me quello con
la banana con la cannuccia e si riempiva
la banana tabellini prima è affezionato
stranamente ha funzionato molto bene e
quindi quell'estate il mio preferito mi
dispiace che il primo nome uscito
bellissimo perché erano ancora col
cioccolato al sezionamento circolato
questa per me come i quali altro che
gigi five minutes class volete che
testiamo descrivete se lingua di cui noi
andiamo negarli e vediamo e li
riproponiamo lasciate ormai che volete
vedere altri trucchetti lines che lascia
un po a patto caterina scoccare se
volete vedere i nostri esperimenti i
nostri video kattinis lines fallendo e
cliccate su quella che preferite e buona
ciao a tutte le varianti adesso pia